you ready I'm ready alright ladies and
gentlemen welcome to another episode of
your favorite podcast you know the name
wow this is a [ __ ] podcast right now
holy [ __ ] we do it live this is the
singer Mike so give it to the guests let
me see what you got yeah we got Matt to
be coming in crystal clear that's right
you'll be hearing me with the echo oh
not that [ __ ] get-go from Geico
you need insurance when I come around
[ __ ] I'll give you a big pound
quarter-pounder [ __ ] CCH pounder
all I can do is say pounder and a
freestyle in 15 [ __ ] years oh I
love it
ladies and gentlemen mr. man
all right I just got to tell you right
off the top yeah way better than Chris
that's the only time I want to talk
about there [ __ ] my heaters came
on in with yeah okay ma with like a
little bit of flow a little bit of
action the thing about Chris is that if
he doesn't want to do a thing he won't
do he's not [ __ ] ever doing it but
you know at least he took the mic I've
had other guests who have been like real
dick kind of [ __ ] about it like now
like just like I'm not doing that and
I'm like it just it messes up the whole
you know but me anyway before we start
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
podcast
longtime friend we don't talk enough mr.
Matt D'Elia long time so here you are
man yeah you know it's well you know
what I love about doing a podcast is you
get to bring people in and like have
like a deep conversation that we don't
normally ever have for sure but I think
I have some misconceptions about you
that I want to address now great because
I feel like you a pretentious artsy [ __ ]
you know and knew that was coming
let's get out of the way like you might
you want to watch like if you go see a
movie you know you're not gonna see it
unless it's like Swedish it's like got a
green tint on it and it's like
everything's incoming
that sounds good [ __ ] well I'll tell you
what I'll tell you what the truth is I
look like that yes and I definitely know
I look like that uh-huh
every time I'm in Silver Lake I see
everybody with a [ __ ] beard oh yeah
here I'm like I need to you should be
writing the script at like a off-brand
coffee shop right now let me say
something I've looked like this in fact
I basically been wearing these clothes
since I was like [ __ ] 17 right so I
was like doing this strung out mother
looking [ __ ] for a long time
okay before it was cool
and it's still not cool but I'm still
[ __ ] doing it but yeah I mean the
thing all right I get this a lot because
like my friends and people around me
they think of me as like particularly a
movie snob yes
are you a snob but here's the thing I'm
not a snob I just I like what I like I
do try to see [ __ ] everything now
okay and here's the thing before I ever
made actually made a movie I was like
the most judgmental [ __ ] that I made
when I was like this is the
hardest thing ever right and if you can
do like if you can make a movie 90
minute movie let's say that's five
minutes five good minutes you did
[ __ ] good oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you switch
hogs changed your perspective I mean
completely now um you you grew up like
like you're the one that kind of
followed in your do you feel like you
followed in your dad's footsteps more so
it's kind of interesting now that all
three of us are working actually working
in the same industry because he's I grew
up around on sets but it was always TV
usually network TV right right and Chris
obviously doesn't stand up I'm an almost
all of everything I've done is in an
independent film space right is
obviously the same industry right but as
you know if you've done a [ __ ] indie
yes I have no it's not the same as
walking onto something because you know
it's the [ __ ] night and day but it is
the same kind of [ __ ] so when we all get
together and talk about our work it the
day-to-day is very different but overall
it's kind of the same kind of [ __ ] I
just but you still didn't you still
didn't like denied it you're no no no
here's the thing about pretentious don't
skirt around it it's fine
I'm very pretentious about a lot of
things you know I'm I'm I'm gonna I'm
probably an [ __ ] about this yeah I'll
give you that I'll give you that if and
if someone wanted to say you're
pretentious [ __ ] oh good okay but giving
it like what movie have you seen
recently that you were like either all
right how about this what movie have you
seen that like everybody liked and you
were like I don't get it hmm or what
movie have you seen that you were like
regardless of people saw or not you were
like my god that was one of the best
movies I've seen in a long time okay
recent in your recent okay okay so I got
one for you that we could talk about but
give me give me you the one that
everybody that I've been talking to
loves and I'm like oh I can't wait to
hear what I guess there's two and
they're different sides of the spectrum
this year uncut gems okay everybody's
flipping out on I was like I don't
maybe I don't get it because I like what
I here's the thing though part of being
a [ __ ] snob and seeing everything I
do
you like to think peel back the [ __ ]
that I do like about a thing you don't
like even if I'm like I'm not into
movies like that was kind of cool it's
cool
uncooked uncut gems is different but I
just didn't have the response people
walking out of the theater like holy
[ __ ] the Sandman's a [ __ ] legend and
he is but like but that's a [ __ ] but
see I think that that's what it's about
it is so let's say it was some unknown
actor playing this role might not be a
great movie but when you have a body of
work for someone that has done something
a certain way for so long and then they
do something like this that's part of
what it is becomes a part of the now
entirely absolutely but you take that
into account here's the thing now and
this is a thing that I think I get
caught up a lot on when you know what
somebody will judge a movie and they'll
be like for that kind of thing I like it
and I don't I don't my brain doesn't
work like that yeah like I love The
Naked Gun as much as I like the [ __ ]
Godfather oh good and to me they're just
a great they're just great right those
are just great great great movies I
don't care that one's way more serious
so we okay so I guess what you're saying
is let's not like put everything in
category its to justify like it or not
yeah let's say what are great movies and
these are the criteria for great movies
and for you could be like it's the
Godfather or its airplane yeah a gun and
I'm kind of with you on that because
when you look but I do think that like I
liken it to basketball where you go
who's the greatest player ever and then
you go okay but like by by position I
think it's important because a center is
only as good as the people that give him
the ball right but once he has the ball
he could be the greatest player
Absolution you know I mean yeah so I get
what you're saying both so what's the
muscle uncut gems is one of them and
what's the hell did you see the 1917 one
I did all right that's a good example
because that movie technically is the
most insane [ __ ] it's unburrow
believable I was in the theater as
somebody in the industry yeah I couldn't
help but being a seeder going like this
how the [ __ ] did they do that I was like
there's a scene of like you see the lake
and it's like and then they're walking
across he's like where's the cameraman
where's the sound guy how are they doing
this you know it must have been like a
magical like moving assault to me just
technically that was one of the greatest
movies I've ever seen which alone makes
it worse
yeah and here's the thing about that
though and I I actually fully agree it
made me think about how the [ __ ] are
they doing this but that took me out of
the movie do you know what okay agreed
okay okay but I think that we have to
remember that we're in the industry okay
yes it's like if I'm watching comedy and
I'm like you know you don't you know yes
director when you're watching you go
plan on like that choice yes so but but
in defense of what you're saying is
that's happening that means I couldn't
suspend my disbelief because what they
were doing wasn't but I think this is
different yeah it is much it was so like
first of all the first shot in the movie
I didn't know anything about the movie
okay okay I didn't know anything okay so
ten minutes later I'm like he hasn't got
the camera right right when that six in
yours like oh I get it but he's gonna
know that at all you don't know I was
blown away out but then you start doing
this doe because I'm in the industry I
go oh they cut it right there yeah right
only because but it's because of how
amazing it was yeah you know what I
remind it reminds me of watching like
David Copperfield in Vegas it's a
similar thing it's it where's the trick
how it [ __ ] is doing I still and I
enjoyed that part I think that was part
of the experience that's what I liked
about that movie yeah because the one
thing that I think the problem when you
try to do a one-take movie like that is
that there's the inevitable lulls you
can only rush them so much right whereas
if you could cut you could just [ __ ]
cut to the next thing yeah the trick is
like making work I think you run the
risk of sort of convoluting it a little
bit but that there's [ __ ] in that movie
which is exactly what you're saying
where the camera just is doing 360
rotations and there's nothing in any
view of anything I and and there's a
scene wide I didn't know this but
someone told me after and I looked it up
it's true in that there's one scene
where he get member to see where they're
pushing the van out of the yeah yeah
that's one of the scenes that it goes
all the way around it Ryan it's like
cool there were grips in like grips and
[ __ ] in the army
that's what I thought yeah I've
mentioned your cables and she I bet they
were cameramen I'm sure they were
dressed like that so they can hand the
camera off and then they can go yes yeah
yeah you know those seems like yeah and
when you're walking in a trench
I mean I hope they got paid double for
that cuz that's [ __ ] magic yeah I'm
just saying this movie is so worth
watching yeah you got to see it it's
just one I was like you if just for the
experience of it you could be like
goddamn because you're looking at my
friend of mine brought up this to me
though my buddy Jason Zumwalt Rider
director he was like they didn't go six
miles cuz that was what the guy said
it's a right right it's possible yeah
but I said to him it don't matter how
far it is yeah they were going across
enemy lines yeah yeah also if you're
looking at if you were like that to me
it's hard to I'm not looking for [ __ ]
like wrong in a movie Robert knows
people that are like that's done
fortunately so that guy and so does it
make you like [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] a lot
less or is it kind of separate for you
like that was [ __ ] but you can
separate it okay it's like I talked
about it on stage a lot because I'm
gonna give you an example to put you in
my head other things that like the
continuity things that just it's I
obsess over okay so like did you see
Avengers endgame I did okay so I'm
watching Avengers endgame I love the
universe I love what they did from
beginning to end
starting with Iron Man and all okay so
they combine the universes so okay
here's Thanos right he's in Wakanda he
does the snap all right when he does the
snap Nick Fury's in New York he
disappears okay
Hawkeye Xin not like a farm in Iowa his
family disappears ant-man he's in San
Francisco he's his people disappear yeah
like I said fan offices in Wakanda which
is supposed to be in Africa right why is
it daylight in all these places see yeah
that is not a thing I would okay that's
me but i annoy the [ __ ] out of myself
yeah okay because but I can't not be
that guy that was my next question is it
because there's a kind of viewer that's
looking for it and likes to find it me
like I knew all right right you're like
I wish I wasn't yes okay I wish I was
like that cause I got a million ways I'm
like I do I'm in a movie and I'm like
you know what I hate about myself too I
think it's just because I've watched so
many movies and just being a stand-up
you just kind of like get to know people
and you get to know situations yeah
this guy that's the killer I'm talking
about I'll talk about 10 minutes in I'm
like this is what's gonna happen so I
can't go to movies with people kill my
friends are like don't [ __ ] say
anything because they don't get it at
all yeah and I forget it I'm just that
guy you know to me in your DNA it's just
in my DNA so I'm like I know it's like
if I see there was this movie with
Angelina Jolie
Ethan Hawke yeah yeah wait I know that
he's a killer yeah yeah okay and then
the other character in the movie was
like okay this is my point if there are
three stars in a cop crime thriller yeah
alright and two of them are cops yeah
guess who the killer is my thing is like
don't give me a movie with three stars
yeah and you know it's a crime drama
because guess who the killer is it's one
of these [ __ ] I couldn't agree
more
in fact when I was living in New York
this [ __ ] movie you ever that Ashley
Judd movie along came a spider oh yeah
yeah okay the on the on the the killer
in that I believe is played by Cary
Elwes Gaines the cop yes okay Morgan
Freeman right row him yeah yes and then
on the bus ads I remember in because I
was in New York there were [ __ ] buses
everywhere it was on the on the bus at
it was a she just faced Sam Jackson's
face and their names above it right then
Carrie Oh was his name and his face
wasn't on it
right this is how much I'm like that to
Cary Elwes is the killer a [ __ ] bus
app you can't yeah but I guess most
people aren't like there they go oh
they're surprised yeah when I get
surprised dude yeah like six cents yeah
yeah well yeah that's like six cents I
was like thank you yeah amazing you got
me yeah you know I love to M night
Shyamalan in the first three movies I
love him and I still go back and watch
his early [ __ ] he into that [ __ ] yeah
you see are you watching servant I saw
the first episode yeah and I want to see
the rest you gotta watch the rest
because it's good it's really good but
dokay you saw the pilot yes he did the
pilot now one thing that I didn't like
about the pilot and it became a set
piece is all these weird angles like
like we're talking like this and the
cameras over here yeah
past my nose to get you and I was like
what the [ __ ] is yeah yeah still wait
did you only direct the first one no no
I think he directed a few okay but it's
but it's actually really amazing show
just because they keep you on your they
keep you like every time I phone ends
you go what yeah you know I like about
that show to it's a half-hour like it
easily judge SFO [ __ ] with the format
now cuz TV people talk a lot about the
golden age of television and it it is in
a lot of ways but one of the coolest
things I think is that format the length
of the of an episode because usually
it's a if it's a drama or a thriller cop
show whatever the [ __ ] hour long period
always right no and a comedy is a
half-hour always period no matter what
yeah now and nights like that's gonna be
a half-hour and it's like it sounds like
is that gonna work and then you watch it
you're like that's [ __ ] amazing why
is this the only thing doing this yeah
yeah this again like i you know i think
i think i think the problem I have is I
have too much knowledge in my head about
the person which goes back to your point
about uncut gems so it's like Eve here's
here's Sandler who we know him as and
it's like it's like that it's like that
Pulp Fiction role yeah for like Travolta
totally you know like this is his role
were now we're gonna look at him and be
like oh he's gonna be he's gonna be cool
again yeah like what's this like like um
Garry Shandling started playing villains
yeah like what's his name what's the
thing that made what's that other oh my
god that made what's the afterlife movie
the comic and then you know just Ricky
Gervais no no judging Milo Albert Brooks
Albert bro
oh yeah yeah Albert Brooks is now he
plays he plays a [ __ ] in every movie
yeah that's true you in drive yeah yeah
I think this is now Sandler's time to be
like okay I'm gonna be that guy I mean
you know I like Sandler there was a
there's a thing with uncut gems where
people are flipping out about it like
he's never seen it yet okay I won't ruin
anything for you but like he's he's sort
of I see him as becoming like the next
like you know Bill Murray's like this
insane all right on touch I feel like
he's on the way to that which is what it
is like it bothers me but I'm like I
don't know in a movie you know I mean
like I did was being a [ __ ] movie you
know
like one serious movie in for a while I
mean he wasn't punch-drunk love I did
[ __ ] love him in that show but uh and
I got nothing against Sandler but just
the whole freaked out of the novelty of
him doing this kind of movie ride where
I was gonna kind of colored that a bit
more Oscar isn't like when member when
Pacino won it was like that was [ __ ]
one front he shouldn't one for sentiment
dude it was just a robbery that year you
know but it's like one of those things
were you like that becomes a factor in
the things
Scorsese went in for the departed and
[ __ ] all right Lifetime Achievement
right cuz the part it wasn't one of his
better movies even close and that's when
like Leo DiCaprio was on this thing
where he's gonna die in every movie
right yeah yeah well his thing was like
I gotta be an adult in every movie yes
because I'm like this kid teen
heartthrob so for like 10 years he was
like I'm dying and every every [ __ ]
movie's got to die yeah it was like you
know the Blood Diamond departed yeah
what was it was like to others where I
was like a buncha Caprio dies in this
DiCaprio died and there was a whole
decade of dekappa what's uh what's a
dream job for you oh man all right you
know what I like a lot
uh speaking of DiCaprio I mean he's the
kind of guy that can get this [ __ ] made
so if we're talking dream like pipe
dream [ __ ] mm-hmm like a big-budget
[ __ ] period thing were you just like
here's what I like about period stuff it
can't really get dated because when
you're making something now you're gonna
make it in the trends of now the style
of now with the intonation is
everybody's voice of now gotcha
when you're making a period thing it's
never really gonna be dated because that
period is already dated in our minds
right so if so so I mean I don't know
why the [ __ ] I'm this is the first one
I'm thinking about polite cause I'm a
pretentious [ __ ] [ __ ] but Stanley
Kubrick's Barry Lyndon write you that
movie takes place when it when it takes
place it takes place when it takes place
so you're not gonna whereas in 2001 that
should take place in the future right
and it can look dumb like that doesn't
look like the future yeah isn't it crazy
with but you go back to all those things
and they go this is gonna be 2004 and
it's like and it's but the thing about
it is that technology they think it's
gonna happen
look so dumb so dumb it looks dumber
than if they just did it as a [ __ ] of
the day and if you're doing a period
thing you and if you especially have
enough money but
like what do you mean like build like
like the old scold English crazy movie
about like a general like losing his
mind in a Revolutionary War sure gotcha
gotcha I just came up with that it's
gonna be so that oh oh okay that's but
like then what are you working on like
what is like right now okay so I'm
actually making another movie with my
next movie with Chris is in it oh wow
the first time you've other than his
special yeah no we've never yeah that's
right I directed Chris is special but he
fired his father yeah dude it was it was
actually great if he fired my dad and
hired me all like the same moment
basically so he fired my dad and my dad
was it's I mean I don't want to speak
for him but he seemed like a little of a
little butthurt about it you know and
then he turns around he's like Matt will
you do it and my dad was like that's the
best firing of my [ __ ] life yeah it
was the one person he's happy to use a
[ __ ] job - I love you dad I text him
every holiday
dude he loves it when you do that yeah
cuz I'm with him every holiday he's like
you know what text me I'm like actually
I [ __ ] do Eric [ __ ] Griffin
Secretary's day it was great I got to
work with him on blunt talk with uh
first time I was like it was like great
to see him and I loved uh how to get
away with murder
oh yeah I still watch that show I don't
think he's not doing it anymore but I
loved that show I think what's-her-face
is just phenomenal viola
yeah dude she's like he's phenomenal and
I would visit him on set sometimes and
just watching every once in a while
mainly through him being around him and
he cuz he's worked with her and like
James Spader and Alfred Molina yeah his
actors who are just like so good that's
right Boston Legal yes he was a
showrunner Obama legal right yeah and
you just around him and they're so pro
and so [ __ ] good that they'll be
carrying on a conversation with you
eating a [ __ ] banana and then
suddenly like rolling sound speeds
action and they're just like talking to
you and then suddenly they're not only
in the scene doing their job but there's
so good Alyssa Leo was locked in Melissa
Lee it was like I'm dying up here all
right yeah there's a scene where she
freaked out on set about something that
camera people Woody's got a freakout
meltdown right right and then it was
like we filmed the scene yeah and I
wanted to go like this yeah cuz they're
just so good and so tapped in I know and
then but there is something that I don't
know if I could be that great of an
actor because I don't have that like I
don't know because I don't talk about it
the way they talk about it yet you know
you know like when you watch an award
show and somebody wins an award then
they have this kind of like really like
ridiculous you know like the art of
acting and this is a special you know I
just when I hear that I just go yuck
I don't think about it - we're thinking
about it yeah but it doesn't mean I
can't tap into my the way I'm thinking
about it but then right it's like a
universal way that these artsy types
think about things I mean award shows or
the worst example of that because
they're just there to like celebrate
them and what they do know what we do is
so whatever and it's just like [ __ ]
actor hood like I love actors but who
gives a [ __ ]
yeah I'm like talk like you know nobody
actually gives a [ __ ] but but then at
the same time though in defense of that
I don't know if you play if you are you
into sports you play fan yeah yeah big
baseball big fantasy baseball okay so
that if you alright if you play fantasy
baseball there's a way that when you're
playing fantasy sports that you talk
about it with your friends that you yeah
yes you're talking about it like you're
the actual GM of a real team yeah now
from the outside people that are not
into that they want to go like this dude
this isn't real hundred percent I don't
want that [ __ ] I get him out of
here this is escapism yeah so I so that
in that way I think that when actors are
and they're up there on their award show
it's going like you know so our table
but that's them playing fantasy football
it is but this is a big but you're not
on [ __ ] TV when you derive right
right if you were you'd wrap it up and
be like thanks for my award
you gonna be like well on my team the GM
they imagine like you know when I
drafted football awards [ __ ] yeah um so
I mean how is he being from such a leg
are you guys you guys consider
yourselves a famous family and when are
you gonna do your part well no well no
and I would say because of me honestly
Chris is well first of all Chris is
unbelievably famous yeah you walk around
with Chris as I'm sure no it's
ridiculous it's like but what what suite
what's to my perspective because Timmy's
just my [ __ ] brother right of course
of course so but there was a time he's
he was on the arc of his he was on his
way up for a while and he like nobody
really would recognize him so much and
then it seemed like some just like day
it was like suddenly everyone was
recognized yes like four or five years
ago and it was a weird thing for me cuz
it was like this is like this is just a
ship because like it's just me and my
[ __ ] brother me it's like it's my
brother like extremely famous cuz I have
no perspective on it he's so famous
okay then I'm steyr never forget this
wet the Comedy Store we're sitting out
on the front lobby the front porch
whatever you call it the front bar area
and like I'm standing next to him and
somebody goes oh [ __ ] man yo holux
you know him yeah and I'm like he was
[Music]
like well that's how famous somebody is
yeah you know you know so no I just um
one thing I'll say I said said he was on
the podcast and I said to him oh my one
of my favorite things about him is that
he the guy I met this is the same guy
now dude I listened to that episode I
heard you say that and I actually had a
moment similar to like people just
recognizing Chris cuz it again when
I've been very close to in my old life
right so you guys you guys were close
brothers close yes close especially when
he moved out like we instantly were just
like just like 20 years now moved out of
our parents house you know what he was
of age but uh yeah I mean it it I had a
moment when I was listening to that
podcast where I was like that's actually
[ __ ] it totally true but he's exactly
the same I mean I wish he [ __ ]
changed a little bit that isn't
necessarily a guy that's not always good
no he can't be like he's just a weird
like weird mother to attach to dude
sometimes we're not [ __ ] you can't
stay in one place I just want to take
that [ __ ] phone and just be like be
present [ __ ] yes yes and so does
everyone in our [ __ ] fan
family get-togethers dude and he's like
a I mean Chris I [ __ ] love you so I
apologize for this but like so true he
acts like a 16 year old girl when you
call him out for it Oh
everyone says that everyone says it cuz
it's annoying as [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] phone
away this is the most annoying part
though he's not just on his phone
playing loud as videos what people are
told
I don't think of himself well that's the
thing I was with him on Christmas when I
was a [ __ ] you but the season season two
of you promote yeah yeah and it midnight
came and that's what Netflix drops their
[ __ ] and he was like you want to watch
you and I was thinking I mean I'm not
even an actor so [ __ ] it but like I was
saying I can't even imagine a world or a
thing with me in it to look at becomes
available and I want to watch it right
away right where I don't even want to
see a picture of me oh you're like that
I am like that do you know what i I've
never been like that yeah you know
because I have this thing to like
suspend my disbelief about like that's
why when I watched I'm dying up here and
I'm looking at myself and there was a
part where I felt like yeah I felt like
I did a good job because I wasn't
looking at it like oh that's me right
you know but you're a performer though
and that's your trade and you're so used
to it yeah that's what you've embraced
right it's what you are and some people
performers don't still don't want to
look at those do you see that [ __ ]
Adam driver [ __ ] we're not
okay so Hebrew this is amazing actually
he was on it and had some NPR show which
nobody [ __ ] listens to but he was he
was talking about marriage story which I
actually haven't seen that I haven't
seen this I don't want to be depressed
yeah yeah oh so so marriage sucks yeah
you know I mean before a filmmaker yeah
I want to see that what the [ __ ] you
know but he apparently asks ahead of
time for them to not play clips of him
in front of him because he doesn't watch
himself but this is where it gets good
they did it anyway on NPR oh wow is this
somehow either slip to the cracks like
they weren't trying to piss him off or
anything right they just someone from
someone slipped up he [ __ ] stormed
off really yeah so he would had a
lightsaber he was a good thing he wasn't
[ __ ] in character I don't like that
that it's like you you've crossed a line
I you know just a [ __ ] true [ __ ]
you know from working with Sandler
actually cuz I was in murder mystery oh
right yeah yeah yeah that's funny Chris
hit me up the other day he sends me this
text message like like you were good but
anyways one thing I really appreciate
about Sandler is that we do a take and
he wants to look at it oh [ __ ] he wants
to look at it see and I was like oh man
I loved it cuz I looked at it I was with
there watching I was like oh [ __ ] I
don't like that yeah yeah look I'm
walking why don't I read am I doing with
my house like this it's like let me
improve on the performance
let me improve on like okay I did it
that way it's like a thing where let me
not look there at a certain time because
it can get down to a science when you're
doing a bunch of takes and the sake
during the take I'm picking this up yeah
you know I want to know I'm picking it
up at the same time every single time so
the editor you know so you whatever I'm
adding to the performance it's actually
good to see it yeah so like I can
understand like not wanting to see the
finished product but to me I think it's
like disrespect to the product but you
can't like if he can't be like let's sit
and watch Star Wars so I'm gonna see
what it's like and he must think it
sucks yeah I mean it's a good point is
it I mean I will say this not liking to
look at
me is is a reason why I could never
really actually be inactive that's why
you're behind the camera I mean I I just
I and I was in my I mean a movie called
American animal that I was in but this
was like a [ __ ] decade ago and that
was the last thing I ever did as an
actor I was just like I edited the movie
screening the movie I mean it it did
well we sold it was out in theaters and
[ __ ] but dude I was in it and it like
took away from my ability to enjoy it
because I was like oh I don't like
looking at me non-stop yeah and it was
it was impossible to know that that was
gonna be the case but now it's like I
can't do that anymore it's just I don't
like to see me I it's like you know I
have a problem with it it's just not
Yuri like I'm almost phobia is yeah a
little bit yeah well I mean as a
director of filmmaker right you right -
yeah right so I mean that's how I make a
living as a writer right you okay um I
don't even know that that's crazy that
ya know that yeah I mean like as a
casues a thing as a writer you can get
hired ten times a year and write
something that never [ __ ] ever gets
made oh that's right and in some times
you can know this is never gonna get
made I'm gonna take that job
bronze [ __ ] I'm gonna take that job get
paid that's never gonna get made it's
[ __ ] great for me eight weeks [ __ ]
I don't know this why we should be
working together
yeah dude [ __ ] I mean I would work
with you in a heartbeat dude but as a
director as you also know especially
with Indies that [ __ ] falls apart yeah
and you can't rely on a career making
money as a director as a as a movie
director unless you're [ __ ] Darren
Aronofsky you're like well I find that I
did this little I did a little indie
called the first girl I love it was like
a lesbian coming-of-age movie and I was
like they were a teacher of one of the
girls and it's actually a really great
movie you can see it on Hulu
but the director of this movie yeah he's
very pretentious you know I love him all
right but he's to the point where I
think at the time he's probably
different now but at the time it was
like I was he just wants to do those
type of movies right he wrote it yeah it
was just it was just beautifully done
yeah but I go dude you got to go make
yeah the [ __ ] movie right so you
could finance yeah no yeah
that you could do for rest of your life
but if that's hard for some people that
are like I will never sell out that
guy's it it's not selling out it's just
like having a job and [ __ ] you know
you your day job at Kinkos just support
your career you know like a stripper so
who's paying away to medical schools the
same [ __ ]
it's a weird the selling out thing I
think it's a little I mean it's a little
bit easier for me because I can separate
eyes all right for me the way I look at
it as a writer I'll do anything I'll
read your [ __ ] obituary if you pay me
you know I should but like as a director
not only is it what I rather be pickier
about that because it's like it's your
piece of work basically as whether you
give the work away the director sort of
has their name on it and it's kind of
like that's the the authorship is
accredited to the director usually yeah
yeah yeah even though you wrote it
whatever but with a [ __ ] with a
script it's basically all it is is that
the directing will be so much [ __ ]
work it's blood sweat and tears and it's
years writing a script is X amount of
weeks right where I'm not dying over the
[ __ ] yeah computer screen as you're
writing it you know I mean and so I find
that easier to stick with that term just
sell the [ __ ] out when I'm writing you
know that's your that's like I'll just
[ __ ] write and give a [ __ ] you know I
mean and yeah it's something writing is
also for me the easiest one of all of
them you know because it's just I don't
know practice
okay so then as a writer director to
take you back to what we were first
talking about is like when you're
watching a movie you know what's the
first thing that's gonna take you out of
it out of it yeah I honestly and I I
find myself thinking as often I like
almost every beginning of every movie
because to me and it's probably might
have to do the fact that I am a writer
the beginning of a movie any movie has
so much promise unless it's just like
horeb like it sounds horrible then
you're like I can't watch it yeah but
just generally if it's a movie that's
somewhat well made I'll be all just I'll
fill in the potential blanks of what's
to come and then it'll be like well this
is promising it could go there it could
go there and
that's what lets you down yeah but then
it's like but it's a double-edged sword
because I've I've like invented a movie
that there's no there's no reason why
they should make the movie I want to see
right but I've done that in my own head
and there's a thing within parameters
that I feel like I it should be now and
that [ __ ] me in a way and so sometimes
even when I'm like I [ __ ] did not
like that movie I'll still be like
that's cool though
look yeah you know what I'm the same way
too I go what I this is what I found in
sa the last five to six years is that I
have yet to see a truly great movie that
I wanted to go back to the theater and
see yeah its rarity okay so so now I
stopped thinking that those are the type
of movies that are coming out so now I
just kind of go I enjoyed that
yeah I'll never see it again right yeah
like I just saw the last Rambo yeah I
actually enjoyed the [ __ ] out of that
movie dude you know I haven't seen one
Rambo ashamed but it's like that kind of
movie so I might go see a movie and go
people say hey how was that
so we've lowered our expectations so
much and it's like you like it was all
right yeah you know yeah that's the
review of the movie is it was alright
yeah go see it yeah cuz now but now what
this is what I and this is one of the
things I appreciate about Sandler it's
like the move to Netflix yeah it's great
because I watch a Netflix movie yeah
like I want like that Will Smith movie
where he's like it's like a fantasy
world combined with the real world
what's they called oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
have to look it up cuz [ __ ] are
gonna be like you know hey when did it
win was on Netflix is no oh oh oh oh oh
the one with the cop movie yeah [ __ ]
yeah it was one word yeah that right now
the chat is going crazy right now
come on come on come on come on where is
it where is it where is it or not I'm
gonna say [ __ ] burnt it's not that
though yes something like that is right
okay Will Smith Netflix movie is called
bright oh [ __ ]
I loved bright oh sure I did I loved it
looked fun
he's cuz most myth he's just a national
treasure you're not I'm sorry yeah
like Will Smith could be Anne Frank in a
movie yeah you know we'll walk in that
theater like we'll tour that he was all
quiet the size was a bit of a mismatch
but yeah he pulled it off yeah but
obviously bright okay
it was on Netflix yeah I probably still
would have went because I'm on fantasy
nerd like that I probably still would
have bought a ticket but I could see
people being like I wouldn't have bought
a ticket but it's like did you watch it
yeah it's like netflix is great for that
so stay there like he was having some
like a little Nikki and it was really
bad he was like you know what swishy
Netflix and he made some great work it
was some great projects that like it the
expectation is different because once
you have to go to the theater spend
money buy popcorn park and all that [ __ ]
all the effort to go to a theater
sometimes you go I don't know if this
movies worth that a hundred percent but
this movie's worth that yeah cuz it's on
Netflix you said play just hit play I
mean Netflix people a lot of people in
the industry moan about what netflix has
done in the industry and there is some
downside to it dude what's the downside
I find it to be very little downside
because for a filmmaker there's way more
[ __ ] getting made so that just means way
more opportunities as a viewer
there's just way more [ __ ] to watch and
it goes so deep with whatever niche
you're into you like documentaries a
[ __ ] new documentary a week did you
see that one about the cat's don't yearn
about that one you watch that one
alright I want to watch that one I want
to watch the Aaron Hernandez one I'm not
big on documentaries but now I'm
starting to get into it but you maybe
keep going yeah I just think that also
with TV I mean like Netflix I mean it's
this is old but house of cards we forget
cuz she moves so fast that was
revolutionary that was the first show
yeah yeah it was like we're gonna dump
them all like this all at once you watch
him at once that sort of changed what
binge watching even was let's see I'm
against it I don't want you still don't
like it no no I like it listen listen
everybody doesn't want to wait yeah
that's why you make them wait
appointment television so you're into it
before the almost like literally like if
they dumped a game
Thrones like that yeah we would not have
been into it as much because yeah I mean
you you're right about you have to take
time to invest in the characters and
wonder and what's happening like
Umbrella Academy on Netflix mmm enjoyed
it
can't tell you [ __ ] about it in my head
right yeah yeah yeah because I watched
it like this done it was over I'm not
already watched it you you can binge
what I like about Netflix is the ability
to binge watch later and being able to
like here's an episode look in the next
episode now these two are available
right now these four of it that's how
they should do here that'll be like this
whole by letting people watch everything
[ __ ] them [ __ ] you you should wait wait
you'll feel better about it
you make yourself way yeah make you some
where yeah I mean I will say the way I
didn't even mean to do it this way I
thought this is idiotic actually back
when Breaking Bad was still on I thought
it was over and I watched and all five
seasons were on Netflix and I was like
I'm watching all this [ __ ] a [ __ ] hat
I was so behind it you know how everyone
some others a show that everyone's seen
you're like I still haven't seen one I
didn't watch three first three seasons
of that show there you go yeah and I
just was like okay yeah exactly
okay then I was like wow that's great so
then obviously the show is being what it
is I was like yeah throw ball and it
didn't end and I was like oh now I gotta
wait I was so [ __ ] into it and I
expected to see the end yeah and I was
like I feel good when you finally saw it
so that's what I'm saying yeah no you're
right you know I don't like about some
Netflix things is like one of the next
Netflix first started putting like old
TV shows on current TV shows I didn't
realize that they would put on a show
that's never coming back on the air like
I was oh I wish I could remember the
name of this show but I just started
watching it and it was like it was about
like a spaceship earth was about to go
bad and they built this spaceship that
it was gonna be a hundred year travel to
another place to colonize a planet and
it was basically about the people on
this ship going to this right it was it
called the expanse no okay but that's a
different show okay so but what it
turned out is it was just an experiment
and the people on the ship didn't know
they were actually in a warehouse and
like Reseda
and they didn't know they were trying to
like Royale whatever they were trying to
do but anyways I was so gripped come to
find out they only did one season and it
was on like it was all like effexor it
was on some network that they canceled
him right so you know I was fully
invested in like these [ __ ] not
even coming back so I hate that so now I
know I go let me see is this show or
researching yeah did they end it what's
going on you got a research but you know
okay so that's did so that we're both
talking about the upsides and downsides
to Netflix for you know I mean let me
just say why I don't like Netflix as
someone in the industry a so like all
the student is taking away money out of
the actress pocket well that is that is
the ultimate problem okay yeah in
general yeah it's just you know it's
like so Shonda Rhimes decides she's
gonna sign a big Netflix deal well all
that means is Netflix is gonna give her
all the money yeah and then the actors
in this show we'll never see residuals
yeah and I paid less than they would for
networks run anyway yes yeah but I hear
that they that Netflix cut a deal with
SAG recently that there's gonna be some
sort of scaled if it's on if it's
playing there's gonna be some kind of
scaled thing where they get people are
gonna get more residual I believe he's
good because but that's them to me is
what initially wrong with it you know
the residual thing I mean so many actors
make have their whole careers made their
living off of yeah getting enough work
and banking on the residuals that come
in try being an actor yeah now
[ __ ] are having to retire at
like 50 55 being like I don't get
residuals yes I can't even do this
exactly it's a hobby it's a hobby yeah
you know so that's why I guess like I
say so that's the the upside downside to
Netflix um man I have so many questions
for you now that one's you know what I
had a couple of internet question oh
yeah had somebody somebody that had a
question for you that has anybody on
your podcast changed your mind about
anything oh [ __ ] that is a good question
damn that is a good question III I don't
I actually don't know what I did what I
do know is that there are guests who
have
like broken my mind open in a way
Oh real I'm like holy [ __ ] cuz here's
the thing you you hear about flat
earthers for example right and you're
like and you know how crazy they are
right yeah and you know what you think
of them and how whatever even stupid you
might say they are but you talk to one
and you are forced to confront the fact
that that's a person with a full life
full of thoughts and ideas and emotions
who thinks this thing it's like it makes
you the perspective of your perspective
of that person changes so much because
there's the defining thing they believe
in a flat earth that makes them an idiot
and then you talk to them and it's like
they're just another [ __ ] person and
it it sort of it's sort of strange to to
experience of pretty relatively normal
conversation and have empathy or
sympathy or whatever for someone who
like you're just like aren't you [ __ ]
crazy it's easier to put you in a crazy
box right but nobody's really in that
box unless you're running around the
street with no clothes on shop yeah most
people even the crazy ones are pretty
[ __ ] normal
but even though but then what you'd
you're example of like people running
around you actually can that actually
can be explained away easier right
oh yeah yes you find out that they have
some kind of like their drinking problem
drugs there's some kind of thing wrong
that's that I wouldn't that's not even
crazy right the crazy person is a person
that sits there and looks at you and
says you know black people are less than
right oh you're you know the earth is
flat yeah so that's the person when you
go where's this coming from
yeah so you're saying to me then
basically that this just expanded your
your thinking is it made you like let me
not judge let me find out why they get
the way they feel it's more this opening
of of I don't know if empathy is the
right word but it kind of is that where
you're like being forced especially
talking to people some people I disagree
with like talking to [ __ ] hardcore
Republicans deeply religious people and
I'm just and and they don't make me
agree with them but what they do is they
they force me to see that they
our full human beings the things that I
don't like about them don't define
actually who they are they define who
they are until I actually talk to them
and and that has changed the way I look
at other people too because I'll see
someone and be like I [ __ ] that person
that person is this that I disagree with
them they're pieces of [ __ ] but then I'd
be like yeah but like [ __ ] more yeah
exactly and it exert they have that want
needs desires your happiness sadness uh
man I know exactly what you're saying
people don't like to think that way
because it's harder to think complex
that with that complexity about
everybody because it's easier to be like
piece of [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] friend friend Ally piece of [ __ ]
but it's way more complicated than that
you know I mean I totally agree with you
and I think that that's like so like I
used to be a person that believed like I
was one of these like old heads it's
like the young people are too sensitive
yeah right yeah and I realize they're
not sensitive they're just stupid right
yeah yeah ignorant they don't know yet
it's so like so they think that
everything can be summed up in 140
characters right yeah and so they have
like it's like you know I hate I love
this this way but they never delve past
why do I feel this way yeah or somebody
says something that is upsetting they
never asked I wonder why they said that
where are they coming from take the time
to be like because you might find out
where they're coming from and you'd be
like oh that's actually why I think
you're an [ __ ] right right right yeah
I mean but it's like we just there's no
real level of like thought and
communication anymore and it's just like
that'sthat's just a really frustrating
thing you know you could you you're a
very level-headed guy and I do you think
that that is from being from such you
have a great family you know and you
know Chris talks about this a lot even
into his stand-up yeah yeah yeah he's
like no I did I didn't do comedy because
I was molested or I didn't do comedy
because I had one a single parent no he
had a two-parent home yeah a wealthy
family you know you get a brother a dog
you know you had this great family yeah
and so like tell me like how did how is
it coming from such a stable home house
do you credit that to the way you are
right now I mean definitely I definitely
credit that I would also say though
my family is very that me would come
from the club but it's like the classic
Italian family thing everybody's loud
and got an opinion and everybody yelling
each other I mean I brought the friends
girlfriends whatever over for family
dinner and for the first time they're
like why is everyone so mad at E I'm
like are you [ __ ] kidding me this is
the best time I had all week right and
so it's sort of it's hard to upset me
with someone's attitude ah and so and
also though as a kid being sort of
exposed to these extreme opinions often
very very different and you and you're
sort of seeing the adults do it while
also in this familial setting and it's a
safe setting where you can really sort
of rip someone apart basically but in a
way where it's this really like nuanced
way where you clearly it's a loving
thing and the banter are almost like
teasing of it becomes like the fun of it
you know I mean it's so it's like it's
it's it's harsh its argumentative it's
deeply opinionated it's at loggerheads
with one other but but it's it's all
within like the same scope of like a
familial thing and this is what I'm
saying it's like it's like like you
couldn't do that on Twitter well Twitter
the thing about [ __ ] Twitter and by
the way the word you use which is one of
my favorite word's nuance dude and
nuance is what is missing yeah
from young minds yeah what is it is the
Twitter thing I mean that that there's
no there's I mean Twitter's the death of
new on yes and the problem the problem
is problem there's so many problems to
me at least especially with social
medias one thing Twitter in particular
is a [ __ ] Hellmouth dude yeah that
but you I can actually get depressed
minutes just going to my feed people
just there's everyone's so [ __ ]
absolute everyone says lack and white
about what they [ __ ] dick and you're
just like dude who is this benefiting
and I think it's just about this like
they're putting forth this persona that
they believe is the thing that their
fans
or their listeners their audience
whatever are relying upon them for but
the result is this everyone's yelling
you but they think out to nothing
no one's listening there is yelling this
shit's not a conversation no
conversation going on yeah it's really
weird it's like it's hard to do
something this kind of platform - did
you see comments and you go and the most
upsetting thing about our certain types
of comments is like from the from the
how the comment is written I'm like you
weren't listening yeah yeah that's the
heart look I don't mind some dialog
right yeah somebody being like I
completely disagree with you and this is
why yeah every like oh we're engaged now
let's do this
that's not what it is it's like just
like you know and then and then littered
with insults at the same time you know
the the Matt let me let me [ __ ] paint
a picture for you and tell tell me how
hard this would be for you to believe
you're you're watching something on
YouTube or your or your listeners
someone's podcast and you think of
something mean and then you write it and
share it with the world imagine like
doing that just yeah I know what the
[ __ ] is that when you say it like that -
it's like that's what people are doing
like I had a comment just just today or
whatever it was like I mean I made a
comment about somebody saying some
things and I was like you know why I'm
saying this exactly yeah like why like
what do you do like like like you all
the choices you have it'd be one thing
if this was the only podcast right yeah
like that okay so then yeah you want to
be like yo what are you talking about
boom boom boom but like you could just
go like this
click I'm gone yeah I'm gone from your
life I'm gone from your world but you
want to say like you want to make a
comment like well you were talking about
this nonsense for an hour I'm like so
you're telling me that you listen - yeah
- listen just to get mad yeah I think
that's what people think it is
I think they listen the game and this
one piece of [ __ ] was saying like like
then that you wanted he wants to be like
you know trying to like psychoanalyze me
you know I mean like those are the ones
like you know I'm like oh my god but why
did but then like I have a problem like
well I I engage yeah you know Chris and
I had the same problem Chris is like
he'll like you know say some [ __ ] to
people like you know it is hilarious to
me because I
that energy he gets riled the fun get
riled up and on the site but it's like
y-you know I got a stop for me I got it
I got to stop getting riled up but at
the same time I want to look because
occasionally somebody's Saints in there
I want to be like okay let's have a back
and forth we have every once in a while
it's a valid thing and the way criticism
is supposed to work which is like
there's this thing I was thinking maybe
you could try this and you're like oh
yeah
thanks yeah yeah but I mean it's it's
here's here's what the ultimate thing of
what it is for me if you're the kind of
person that would say that [ __ ] to my
face
write it down on Twitter fine fine but
you're not you're gonna [ __ ] write it
up and snipe at me or whoever the [ __ ]
on Twitter or whatever the [ __ ] and if
you saw me in person you wouldn't even
[ __ ] say [ __ ]
so like dude if you're gonna be
consistent fine you're gonna be a
consistent piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever that's just how you are but if
you're gonna be a [ __ ] little [ __ ]
but hiding behind your screen and if you
saw me in [ __ ] person you just walk
the other way how about this they're
already hiding because like it's like
some dumb ass username sometimes they
don't even have a Bobby thank you
comment so you're Nautilus comments I'm
like all right no [ __ ] you yeah I don't
know put your name on it yeah put your
name on it yeah cuz I'm putting my name
on it yeah this isn't like username you
know truffle head truffle head podcast
people like who's that guy you know who
the [ __ ] I am
this is Eric Griffin Eric Griffin calm
you can know why I go to my website you
got my email you got my Twitter you got
my Instagram you know exactly who I am
I'm putting my thoughts and feelings out
here for the world to digest you are
just being a little [ __ ]
yeah just let go like okay what does
that do for your life I think people
honestly are so [ __ ] sad and lonely
that they're just lately maybe I don't
want it no it's not even that it's like
dude I've been [ __ ] sad and lonely
too I don't go around [ __ ] on people
I don't know for no-shoe [ __ ] it doesn't
make me feel better
no but it's like this is the thing I
don't like I said I don't mind criticism
one at all my criticism too I don't mind
a funny joke right yeah so like if
you're gonna call me fat make this [ __ ]
funny make it good make it good
because I'll laugh yeah right right yeah
but don't tell me like just one comment
was like I think the fat is getting to
your head you know it's like that's just
you being a [ __ ] yeah you're an [ __ ]
you don't mean and that's the thing is
like let's check it out the fat can come
and go but you're lonely
kunti mine yeah you're always gonna be a
hassle yeah that's never gonna [ __ ] I
could get on a wake of playing right now
and I'm still gonna be dope yeah true I
think there's a there's a whole thing
with a certain kind of person where they
think they're funny and they mix up
being funny with it's like they think
they're doing a sarcastic kind of humor
that they're like gonna be able to do a
banter thing with with like a commute in
your case like a famous comedian right
right and it's just like a it's not
funny be it's just out of context and
you're only thinking it's good because
it's something to do in your head that
isn't clear and see you just sound like
a [ __ ] mean person right so like none
of it's working out yeah what is the
thing you're doing
yes it's just empathy is what's needed
you know and that's just what's missing
it is you know that's what's missing
that's why you know it's like I was like
I just did a solo episode the other day
after the Kobe Bryant you know and all
that stuff happened you know then like
you know it's like Ari Shaffir do you
know what the [ __ ] you did that thing
you know and I didn't talk about it I
didn't want to mention his name on my
solo episode because I was like but
whatever yeah it was like it's like you
know what wait he's a because I'm sure
how what he's dealing with right now it
I'm sure there's regret did a massive
blow back on them oh yeah I mean this
already come out with an apology or
something but it doesn't even matter my
thing is like it's just there's a lack
of empathy there and I feel like I have
sometimes a lack of empathy when I'll
with the how I choose material you know
okay so like so I'm trying to work on
ahead
Neal Brennan on the podcast and he was
just really going at me about this this
particular topic and I was like
afterwards I was like you know what
that's that's true there's a way to like
you know you do beat you yeah like don't
don't water down yourself to the point
where you don't feel like you're being
true to yourself but at the same time
like be thoughtful in
empathetic to like the characters and
your jokes in your story right because
you think that the thing that really got
the thing that I think was wrong about
what Ari said was just the fact that
there's nine people on there I know yeah
it's nine yeah you know and this is
crazy there's three you know like did
people don't even understand all the
people that were on that on a helicopter
yeah like Kobe so famous yeah bright yes
three white girls were on their
helicopter and nobody knows who the [ __ ]
- yeah I didn't think about that when
when I really that's how famous yeah
when a really famous celebrated person
dies within a in a group imagine being
like knowing or being close to someone
who was in the group but wasn't the
famous person I know I always think like
if I'm on a plane I'm looking around
like okay if this plane goes down it's
gonna be like can be near a Griffin guys
you know it's like oh [ __ ]
there goes like sting yeah then you're
the one that comes out like the second
week was on that flight like wow look at
that you are uh we did good man I don't
usually go for you do do an hour hour
whatever I don't I don't know what you
got going on to keep you but like look
man I just I really appreciate you
coming on you know I think that we
should talk more
I'd love to you to come back I mean let
me tell you the story about when I met
you though
dude let's do it alright so I actually
was think about this driving over here
and it's [ __ ] funny I brought it up
with my brother a few months ago and he
remembered one part about it at the part
at the very end but it was at the 101
this was I mean I don't even know how we
used to go there long have you known
Chris [ __ ] man over 10 years so it's
probably 10 years ago I guess and it was
at the 101 and it was I don't remember
how we you met us separate and and he
was like my buddy Eric coming and I
remember at that time when you guys were
all still starting out kinda basically
still very much on the up yeah
the the comics he was around it was like
every once in a while just a true freak
would be around and you'd be like Chris
you can't hang out with that
[ __ ]
like that guy's a killer or some deal
got those guys they go they open front
oh yeah Michael anoche your [ __ ]
freaks having energy around yeah yeah
but this like every once a while and so
he said my friend buddy Eric's coming I
was like I was like oh we'll see how
about this [ __ ] like but then
you show up and I was like oh I like
this [ __ ] like right away you
know for some reason I don't remember
the context but I do remember yeah you
kept acting out what it's like to bust a
nut for some reason okay and the reason
I remember it is twofold
one I was like I can't believe I just
met this guy and he's and he's doing
this in front of me like this is [ __ ]
hilarious but every time you would act
out busting in that this is the part
that made Chris remember uh uh you would
go like this and I'm sorry cuz it's
gonna be extremely [ __ ] loud but like
ten times and now and and people were
like looking over and [ __ ] you're
just like everybody's like dying dude
and that's my memory of meeting you you
acting out busting a nut those are the
good times you know and that guy say
that's what I'm saying about what I
appreciate about you know your family
just your dad even your mom your mom is
the best
yeah your mom's the best your families
that you know if there's like a
groundedness that you guys have and I
think that's but you know really if I
think it's from your parents you know
yeah and it's great that that that
energy is out there and that's why you
both are successful and you know I wish
I wish you all the best and like I say
yeah I love you to be a regular like
what we should do is like go start going
to see movies we should come back and be
like let's talk about the movie because
you know to recap 1917 was Fargo
phenomenal.i we both recommend you see
you guys see in that movie and you know
just to see where what you know and also
just to chitchat and catch up on life I
mean I love doing this format because
like I say you just you sit down with
someone that you have
had like a conversation about life with
your and then like things happen and
come out it's great to share this with
the world because this is what we want
people to do yeah what we're saying to
you is have conversation yeah yeah have
intimate conversation and whatever it's
about will change the complexion of your
mind about yeah exactly you know as
opposed to like imagine if the podcast
was like we just watching a Twitter feed
watching melt all burn just just melt
down the generational slurs and
everything comes like that so you know I
guess that's the the basically the the
gist of the whole thing guys it's just
like you know just just open up you can
have an open mind open heart and just
you know you don't have to agree I'm not
even saying you have to agree with
people it's just that you know but be
open to hearing what they have to say
process it then make your thoughts
boom respond yes that's what the [ __ ]
that's what my podcast is all about dude
I mean I'm talking to [ __ ] yeah
what's the name of your podcast Matt
D'Elia is confused I have less guests
from [ __ ] total freaks all walks of
life Exorcist all the way over like
[ __ ] politicians and scientists it's
it's just a variety of [ __ ] that either
I don't understand and want to or just
perplexes me or just is wild [ __ ] that I
want to learn more about oh and it's
been good dude I mean we got a bunch of
[ __ ] really cool guests but to look
at it steal some clips for my green
screen
yeah I've been saying that I did a funny
one with you and your brother I love
that one just because of what you guys
were talking about it just lent itself
to like me be in the videos not what it
says it is talking about me but but
anyways guys this has been Matt D'Elia
the cool daliyah hell yeah the best
daliyah
yeah Wow Bill's the best bill bill mom
than you bill led think Chris below you
can't see that's what Christmas yeah
they actually they save a spot for you
no I mean yeah
and then we put a curse but anyways
thanks for coming on guys all this
information will be below please share
subscribe and like and I'll see you next
week with some more free content right
thanks for watching thank you
[Music]